what's your name
what's your name Genie now Genie no
disrespect but if I work with you
I should better walk in and go oh Genie
beautiful uh titty meat you have there
and
because I see that but
whatever the scientific term is I'm
looking at Mr
a 4.9 grade point average what's the
what's the science term for uh the titty
meat what's the actual and it's not the
cleavage I mean the cleavage is the
space in the middle I'm talking about
the meat the meat the titty part
and I'm not being foul just you know
whoa
you know what I'm saying just
so I can go through the rest of the day
without pretending
that I don't see which which you
understand what I'm saying I mean let's
work out a deal don't get me fired
having women work with men right is like
having a grizzly bear work with salmon
foreign
honey like so
now you dip the salmon in the honey
right grizzly bears and the salmon get
to walk through comfortable with honey
and fish and good morning grizzly bears
and the grizzly bears is like
hey
man you can't even growl like ah what's
up fish oh my God Human Resources the
grizzly bear just did Grizzlies
so
[Applause]
like I can't even go hey good morning
good morning fish good morning
oh I can't touch it like oh look at that
oh let me just get a little bit of that
fish a little bit
look at that honey oh my God
chicken honey man
favorite
usually I kill fish and eat them stuff
but I just wanted to just rub that rub a
little bit of that
God damn
[Applause]
that's oppressive like you shouldn't
even
and there's cameras everywhere you can't
do like weird stuff behind the back like
why would it be disrespectful I said
what's your name
Terrell if I go tell you Terrell we work
together and I go tomorrow hey do me a
favor let me know when you're getting up
to go to the bathroom so I can sniff
your chair
[Applause]
that's disrespectful because it's sexual
but that keeps me from being
like I think look I think there should
be a holiday
uh for lack of a better word harassment
day but not that sounds whatever but I
mean a day where I get to
find out like because and this is why it
should be harassment day because women
get to be inappropriate sexually all the
time you get to be inappropriate and
when I'm saying inappropriate I mean
say hello to me
Too Close hi
or some weird massage because you think
we're friends and you good morning
little kiss and he's just like oh oh boy
oh boy boy boy boy
and you think in your head man I wonder
if I I wonder if I don't know
but harassment day allows you to be able
to ask
oh yeah I say the Tuesday
before Thanksgiving
[Applause]
you just real cool you walk up you're
respectful you say hey how are you you
know good afternoon Trail happy
harassment day
and you just like say listen I was
wondering all year if you would suck my
dick in a broom clock
[Applause]
and you'd just be like no thank you I'm
not and you play I'm thank you keep the
flowers I just thought
foreign
I made a mistake I thought you was a hoe
all year
because I thought you was a hoe but
you're not
don't go too far ahead of me you ever
try to watch the Special Olympics and
and try not to be uncomfortable because
it's the it's the right thing to do
[Music]
and you're not an [__] but the 10
meter stumble it's
impossible to watch you try to you do
because you're a good person
on your marks it said go
oh my God they fell
and he didn't fall but what's this guy
doing one day he didn't fall but he
didn't run because the starter's pistol
scared him to death so he's just
standing there
[Laughter]
she got a shoot at his feet to make a
move or shove them
now you gotta watch out cause the
javelin guy is
staying straight ahead you know
you know he shots with that sticking
yeah
and if you hit you in your chest you
can't even go
you gotta go oh no everybody
no it's just a small hole in my [__]
my chances
thank you yay
all right eight inches
like I can't spell if I had to spell
restaurant
right
save my mama's life like if
like if somebody had my mama house this
you had a gun to her head it says [__]
spell restaurant
I'll shoot your mother in the head I'd
be like I would look at my mother like
uh I love you
you better look at me Mom she's crying
[Applause]
understand that I
I love you with all my
heart
okay all right all right all right
all right all right all right all right
resp
oh my God here's where it gets
oh Jesus Christ
uh
Rowan
is the it's a A or U or U
all right give me another give me
another word man give me another word
one more word
let's give my mother a chance to live
tomorrow
probably God damn banana all right
banana banana b-a-n
n
is it like seven ends in banana
AAA
[Applause]
I never thought Mike Tyson and the
reason I'm saying this because
[__] now he's fighting like
Farmers they got Mike fighting
anybody
just to say Mike we want to see you
knock a [__] out again
he was so special as a knockout artist
we hated to see him when he got on the
rape beef that I never believed
especially based on the last interview
we had with uh Greta Van suskin
and he goes she goes what do you have to
say to your victims Mike he goes well I
wish I hadn't really raped the [__]
and her mama I wish I had really raped
the [__] and her mama I'm like whoa
that is an innocent man that's the I'm
telling you only an innocent man could
be that angry and say some [__] that
[__] up like I I wish I had a raped
inside I've been in jail for something
instead of raping a [__] and I really
didn't so that's Mike's way of like
figuring it all out
and her testimony years ago which cut me
off even without the interview with
interview solidified it
her testimony he forced oral sex on me
and I said damn he made you suck his
dick that's terrible
he ate a [__] that's when it was like
case
dismissed because
what rapist tries to make you feel
wonderful I
he pushing a long time
and I never eat it rapey how the [__] do
you get shot [__] shut up
if I need your [__] shut up
I peel away to outer lips and
Slide the hood back to exposure clitoris
for maximum stimulation shut the [__]
you can't even make a mean face while
you eat [__] you can't shut up
you better not be enjoying this [__]
[Applause]
Has any woman here be getting a [__]
eating them and going hell well
nope he's eating my [__] somebody do
something
shut up nobody hear your cries
foreign
[Applause]
look at this girl's face like the stone
Indian which that's your girl bro
oh I like that I like that you feel that
you know what he said he said look at
her and look at me that was a compliment
to you or to her
what's to you man I thought you was kind
of good looking
so that head was kind of like over here
but you meant you so but we all thought
you meant that so basically he he was
saying that she's too pretty
they got that misconstrued because they
couldn't believe somebody could be that
much of a lion ass liar
see what happens when you lined up it's
just whatever did she just a friend of
yours so how long you've been trying it
how long you've been trying
[Applause]
how long you been trying to have sex
with her and friendship your way into it
it ain't gonna happen she's gonna use
you until you're finished she's gonna
tell you all kind of her problems she's
gonna have you go out to dinner with her
hair Annie up man have her Annie up man
give it up how long knowing I'm uh uh
not having a good time how long you been
knowing this guy
Michael I don't even know I don't like
her already
said fun
and you've been trying to make this
unfun [__] one day lay down and give
you some booty by what how how how
hey
[Applause]